tellement toujours accueillir tout de
suite celui qui fait les questions 4/3
c'est jean luc lemoine qui va durer
alors pour ceux qui nous rejoignent dans
touche pas à mon poste parce que vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux à nous
regarder donc beaucoup de nouveaux
téléspectateurs sachez que jean luc
lemoine deux fois par semaine ils
s'intéressent à ce qu'ils passent aux
offres dans l'équipe par voilà donc oui
pendant leurs pendants les radios via
des caméras tout ce qui est enfin c'est
un peu vous voyez un peu ce qu'on voit
pas et vous montre aux téléspectateurs
ce qu'on n'a pas envie de voir
est ce que je pourrais vous donner une
petite chose aujourd'hui
exceptionnellement est ce que cette
séquence peut être hors gages
c'est à dire
27 je jugerai après voilà sinon région
va couper beaucoup hein les gars c'est à
dire c'est pour moi aujourd'hui non pas
que oui à la première question bonjour
je m'appelle hirate la semaine dernière
je n'ai pas vu votre mission car j'étais
en train de faire la teuf à ibiza est ce
que vous pouvez me dire ce que j'ai
manqué pas oui je comprends votre
problème est exceptionnellement pour
vous je vais vous faire un petit résumé
car il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
donc partons tout de suite à la
découvrir des images de la semaine à la
découverte dacquois à la découverte pas
à l'aller ouvrir découvrir vous avez
vous avez dit découvrir non mais oui
mais voilà je voulais juste vous rendre
au mas désolé bon à la découvrir dans
des chambres de la famille
[Applaudissements]
vous allez découvrir j'ai rajouté le
faire ça va ça va ça va chercher je suis
pas bon alors il s'engage pour la sto
pour cent jeudi
c'est lui qui fait le jeu all the math
avec le bonnet de bain et les lunettes
bon allez on va commencer cette semaine
comme l'indiquent
alors oui j'ai pris ce que j'ai trouvé
le plus beau sur le net l'événement
marquant de l'indicé qu'une nouvelle
fois pour faire le beau gosse à cyril
avait mis des vêtements trop petits
je suis désolé ça se voit ça se voit je
le sens mais non il s'enfonce il est
temps des sables mouvants la sazof vous
mettez truc trop petit parce que quand
tu es obligé de déboutonner discrètement
ta veste avant de te baisser c'est
qu'elle est trop petite reine va ton
gâteau et là tu as quel âge et ben 18
bon ça va ça va bon heureusement
heureusement sa chemise était mieux et
ben 18 ans tu n'auras 4 d'un cadavre
ces bases et c'est à dieu
[Applaudissements]
vienne le gap laissé le il ne fait que
son travail puisse laisser laisser faire
la police a en tout cas on sent qu'elle
a envie de sortir la peau pietà c'est
pour lui ça ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
pour lui et si je vous montre que les
gens sont plus méchants que moi à alesi
parce que en fin d'émission
lio le talent profite paupières pourtant
fin d'émission lio à faire un compliment
à cyril ce qui nous a permis de savoir
ce que pense était vraiment thierry
moreau de son patron à hildisrieden il
est généreuse obtenons passé à mardi as
tu pas là c'est bien mardi cyril était
blonde et s'appelle laurence ferrari à
laurence qui a commencé l'émission par
un gros mensonge et je pense que le
baudet va passer à quelqu'un d'autre
puisque lens nous a fait un petit
mensonge pour commencer ça lui ôter
toute crédibilité et nous parler de vous
rassurez vous il ne m'a donné aucune
directive sur vous tous
il m'a juste dit de dire un truc qu'il
vous aime évoluer
[Applaudissements]
non mais dites nous la vérité vous dit
tout c'est juste quelqu'un qui me
connaît bien et on voyait appelé laurent
story 2 ans que je suis en a [ __ ] si
vous êtes très pudique candidate cause
d'elle attendez bon évidemment par
addition jean-michel n'a pas fait que ça
hein
il a essayé de rares ce n'est laurence
avec un peu plus de classe que
d'habitude avec vous il parle qu mairie
avec elle
il parle science param name and may fred
scientifique mais c'est vrai qu'il
paraît qu'il ya pas un anus qui se
ressemblent et donc on pourrait très
bien faire mais les aéroports au lieu de
cali rice on pourrait faire la liste pc
ça prend plus de temps on demande aux
gens de se déshabiller à chaque fois oui
il faut le savoir dans le monde idéal de
jean-michel tous les gens présents très
leur anus à la douane
[Applaudissements]
avec deux fils une pour les anus de
l'union européenne et une pour les
épreuves merci jean michel pour tout ce
que tu as fait pour la télé française
sinon pour la première fois nous avons
vu laurence faire un questionnaire
rigolo à l'antenne est ce qu'on a vu mme
bernard de la villardière emporté des
chiffres et des lettres
grâce aux mots prostitution ou pas vu à
la télé n'ont pas vu les raisons je sais
pas si vous avez entendu la remarque
jean-michel ça fait combien de les
trusts le relou c'est le soleil qui
tient vérifier que la vanne est
plausible salle tel boulet non mais
attendez c'est très important pour lui
la preuve regardez le alors que tout le
monde est passé à autre chose à vue vous
avez raison
en fait ce qu'on a vu une mousse party
géante dans les rues d'une ville en
australie très récemment je salue à la
delépine de l'écu
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique ils comptent les votes
de prostitution sur ses doigts et enfin
mardi 12 dérive allez tous les ans fin
mardi nous avons failli perdre un invité
avant son arrêt sur le plateau recevez
cyprien qui pour faire cool s'est dit
que ce serait pas mal de sa cause et sur
un de nos spectateurs
il n'aurait pas dû mal et on va cueillir
maintenant ses prix insubria qui nous
rejoint à la fin on peut leur bourse
suisse et j'adorais le coup de pression
j'aimerais maintenant ces prêts ainsi
ben rien qui nous rejoint sur le pétrole
j'aime beaucoup mercredi en syrie
faisait son grand retour pour son plus
grand plaisir car pour le nôtre soyons
honnêtes c'est mieux quand on n'est pas
là où on est on est en mode est bonne et
c'est sûr on n'est pas obligé de subir
ces chansons pourries et ses mains au q
ha il faut dire que s'il était d'autant
plus heureux que nous recevions nadège
la croix de ces crêtes story qui n'aura
accueilli chaleureusement le parade en
lui parlant de son avenir
c'est avec comme et des lexus moi je
connais le milieu du cinéma
et là si tu veux là le rôle qu'elle a
décrochée à la défense
c'est très encourageant à libon il faut
l'avouer
enora un petit problème de gestion de la
colère on la changera pas et en plus on
les aime comme ça mais bon pour que les
téléspectateurs ne la trouve pas trop
agressive nous allons trouver une
solution
ah oui dès que nous sentirons quesnoy va
pousser un coup de gueule nous
l'obligeront maintenant à prendre une
bouffée d'hélium c'est un petit détail
mais je vais sur ça change tout au
niveau du rendu on ne pouvait pas dire
une jeune fille de 25 ans tu ne
réussiras pas parce que tu as
quand même nadège a quand même beaucoup
de distance par oui et en plus on
comprend ce qu'elle dit quand même plus
et ça c'est moins agressif et c'est
vachement bien
mais quand elle est en du kobus ça
marche bien mais enfin je dis ça je dis
valérie bénaïm et employés trois mots
intelligente à la même phrase ce qui a
beaucoup déstabilisé jean-michel non
mais à l'origine le grand tour c'est un
long voyage initiatique de jeunes
aristocrates qui allaient parfaire leur
[Applaudissements]
magie commence comment vous recruter les
personnes que vous voyez dans les foyers
je ne connais pas ces versets social en
fait aller toujours en grande forme
cyril a aussi très bien vendu nos
invités avant leur entrée ils altaïr et
donc en featuring avec corys cas sur ce
nouveau titre un la djette oriska et je
peux vous dire ça c'est énormissime
qu'on les ait sur le plateau ils seront
avec nous oui c'est énormissime dansoir
keenan et surtout oriska parce que c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas vues sur beaucoup de
plaies au risque
ce chapeau à la contrebasse con je vous
le dis tout de suite vu ce qu'on leur a
fait on aura plus des invités aussi
prestigieux
parce qu'à la fin de l'émission il veut
résumer leurs morceaux le problème c'est
que la petite djette elle a bien plu à
jean michel donc dès qu'on a rendu
l'antenne
il s'est créé en boîte et a commencé une
approche de pachydermes
en attendant c'est derrière elle vous
avez voirol à la pression elle n'est pas
bien elle est pas bien elle ne lâche pas
des yeux un visuel et regardez bien au
passage jusqu'au bout jean michel von
scanner une autre à
[Musique]
une telle rage
non
[Applaudissements]
toujours dans l'odyssée de l'enquêté
mais sony quoi la barre toi est injuste
on voit maintenant des fils à un
ingénieur du son lui maintenant mais bon
ça c'est rien compris à ce qu'a fait
subir cyril à keenan j'ai fait j'ai pas
vu non ça faisait deux minutes que
keenan danser en attendant son couple et
dans la chanson c'est exactement moment
il va commencer son playback que syrie a
décidé de dire au revoir à tout le monde
regardez final c'est le groupe non coté
qui en a rien à [ __ ]
où
tu te prends place il lui confie la
danse et à demain
là
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui qui arrive comme ça là ont
trait aux cours oui les réglages ah oui
c'est vrai mais c'est bien bravo c'est
parce que je ne savais pas qu'on allait
rendre l'antenne
il est resté à peu près oui la santé
c'est pour ça que nous nos invités
chantent quand la tène et rendu la
sentence à micro sait pas chanter mais
l'amitié et la petite et doux après son
fonds sont sans fondement
d'ailleurs question pour finir la résine
est bien allé 2 à la question bonjour je
m'appelle les a
il paraît qu'il faut coucher pour passer
à la télé est ce que c'est une fois au
début où à chaque fois parce que valérie
benaïm allait quand même fait pas ma
démission
[Applaudissements]